yeah I love watching Mr beasts terrorize
people by helping them out yeah that's
the worst form of terrorism and white
supremacy helping him oh yeah just by
clicking play on this video you've
already helped pay for someone to get a
prosthetic limb that is insane imagine
living in a world where 80% of amputees
are denied the care they need to live a
fully functional life this is a
saddening reality faced by those living
in developing and War stricken countries
so we flew into the heart of Cambodia in
Southeast Asia where Darren met with Tom
SAU who is one of the 40,000 amputees
that live there it's this reality that
has brought exceed worldwide in Cambodia
to life despite doing everything they
can to reduce these numbers
unforeseeable challenges have emerged
their two rural clinics vital for most
patients are just about to get shut down
they've been providing amputees with
free Prosthetics and services for over
30 years they are who changed Tom su's
Life by not only Pro if you're where my
my my memory might be a bit off but
essentially due to war that happened
quite some time back in Cambodia when
they relegated to a lot of jungle combat
they ended up planting a bunch of bombs
uh and landmines all over the place to
make it impossible for the Invaders uh
to approach and move forward and my
understanding is that a lot of them end
up dying through that process but when
the war ended a lot of those mines where
they were it was never really mapped out
so a lot of them are still present today
so you think about that there's
landmines you know that are basically
and the thing about landmines a lot of
time is they never they don't kill the
person they have a worsening effect they
actually ma them so that then they have
to be brought back alive so it's a risk
for all the other soldiers who are still
around and then there's also a morale
drop knowing like okay the guy was just
fighting with lost one of his limbs or
whatever it is so they were planted all
over and I think fast forward to today
there's still many of them so a lot of
people who live out in the areas who
moving about end up stepping on one even
though they think the land is safe it
just takes one step in the wrong spot
and then one Springs up and [__] like
that so that's my memory I could be
wrong but that's what I remember what
you want to say we watching another
video of that guy fing people and just
taking advantage of them yeah I love
watching Mr Beast terrorize people by
helping them out yeah that's the worst
form of terrorism and white supremacy
helping him oh yeah yeah there's just
something crazy about watching a white
man go to an Asian country and then
giving them the ability to walk again
you're such a white man what a piece of
[__] oh my God you're being a white male
and the way that you're inflicting
generational trauma on them by giving
them back the limbs they lost due to the
Past it's [__] disgusting you're
making them relive their past that's
crazy crazy with a life time of free
care but also the education she needs to
help thousands of other amputees just
like
her we are just about to witness s Cabo
a 59-year-old woman receed prosthetic
legs and walk for the very first
[Music]
time
so you know a lot of people talk about
Mr Beast and they talk [__] about the
sustainability of stuff but you're
seeing right here it's not enough to
give these people prosthetic limbs you
have to help them with the rehab so that
they can strengthen the muscles and get
the idea in their heads of how to even
walk with the
limb so you're seeing that this is not
just a short-term thing where he's just
giving people a legs he's actually
making sure that the recovery process in
the clinic stay open so they keep
getting the care they need to get better
over time so amazing and I'll say two he
still a white man true and so that kind
of invalidates everything else he's
saying but I'm going to keep talking and
then just finish that with he's a white
male and then just erase everything I
said
to just want to make sure don't forget
all right so like I was saying you're a
white male I'm play I always said this
if you had to choose between losing a
hand and losing a foot I would choose
losing a hand every single
time mhm and I would choose that I would
choose losing both hands over losing one
foot foot if I lived in these countries
God
damn easily sure because wheelchair
accessibility is not a thing over there
no the roads are not paved the sidewalks
are not paved in every spot so you going
to be struggling to even be able to use
a wheelchair anywhere you know here we
have to make a lot of buildings
especially governmental buildings
wheelchair accessible right that's like
mandated by a lot of governmental bodies
over there they don't have any of that
so you're pretty much [__] out of luck
if you your feet don't work your legs
don't
work and using crutches for your rest of
your life that's not a solution either
cuz that ends up [__] up other parts
of your body so yeah it might be oh it's
just a foot no in the places like these
just the foot means you can't work you
can't do
anything yeah you live basically in a
place where not having feet is often
times like good luck going forward with
most of your life so that's just one
thing I want to say sure which one would
you pick hands or feet oh same I I
understand your logic and it makes
perect perfect sense you forgot to say
that he's a white man at the end you
were supposed to say for me well yeah
yeah well yeah yeah yeah
uh I bet Mr Beast is not even your real
name yeah Mr
yeast this make me cry because this
special for her
s it's amazing the work that you guys
are doing over here it mean a lot to me
because I'm also people with disability
it's difficult for me I feel like the
people are why they look at to me I'm so
different maybe they don't like me and
that's why I want to have them because I
know the
feeling I think you're an
amazing person you've been through a lot
and now you can use it to help
others our time with Tom sus and exceed
worldwide was so moving that we want to
do everything in our power to help as
many people as possible and keep these
two clinics open so instead of providing
150 limbs like we originally intended we
are going to be giving away around 2,200
prosthetic limbs to people who need it
over the next
year when we first came here I thought
that we were simply buying limbs for
people that need it but what we've
experienced is that it's so much more
than a limb we're giving back people
their independence we're giving them the
ability to go back to work but most
I realize that we're giving them back
their dignity and their self-esteem like
one their patients
somehow for the disability woman in
Cambodia if I don't have education tool
I'm hard to find a good job right now I
don't have money I'm just earn money to
support my
family this is my goal and my plan in my
future I want to graduate my master
degree of accounting and I want to go to
another country just only one if I can
understanding how drastic the obstacles
in Sam Pal's life are we decided to make
her Dreams Come True by paying for all
her schooling as well as covered all her
travel expenses so she could visit any
country in the world
[Music]
really oh
God if I you know what's crazy is like
you see how happy she is to get her foot
back if you didn't notice her left arm
the fingers are also gone so what
whatever injury she occurred it seems
like her fingers were also taken from
that um I
know it is crazy that people going to
lose so much and be so happy at even
what appears to be one of the smaller
things in life that cost so little and
uh yeah Mr Beast videos are the only
videos that ever get me like emotional
every day when I watch them not all them
but like these ones I don't know why
they just be getting to me if I can earn
money also I can do everything I can Dy
more to from school I can have people I
really thank
[Music]
you sow is one of the thousands of
extraordinary people being aided by
exceed worldwide's lifelong
program like School teachers paralympic
medalists and even the cutest elephant
named
Chu on the first day Tom sus mentioned
to Darren and the team that her current
prosthetic collects make her feel very
short so the team worked tirelessly
throughout the entire night so we could
surprise her with the a new pair of
prosthetic limbs but before I do that I
need to tell you about the sponsor of
this video Battle Run because they
helped us transform thousands of ampute
lives Battle Run is a free-to-play
racing game that uh Dan can you put me
in the game available on Android and iOS
where you can race against friends or
against other people around the world in
action- pack stages you can play in the
classic four player competition I
normally never watch ads but I'll watch
it for this one or a 12 player survival
Battle Royale compe hey I've never been
invited to play along be sure to watch
any ads we
do thank
you well now that it allows 12 players
I'll consider
it Blast away your competition with tons
of explosives and abilities to get first
place you can download it from oh uh
this QR code or using the links in the
description now Darren take it away TS
you told us that you wanted to be 12
yes and so we bought you a new pair of
legs are you ready s
yeah look at we almost the same height
now yeah thank you so much thank
[Applause]
you thank you so much for watching this
entire video by doing that you're
allowing us to help make the world a
better place subscribe all right there
you guys go I'll have the video in the I
think um I didn't want to only cover Mr
B's videos Whenever there was a
controversy so I thought it'd be a nice
change of place to just cover one that
doesn't seem to be making the rounds at
all um yeah it's great I love seeing
this kind of stuff and I think for a lot
of people who've never been to these
parts of the world you know me having
grown up around a lot of that kind of
stuff you see how day-to-day life is
very difficult for people who have all
their limbs who have all their [__]
together it's incredibly difficult uh
for a lot of people to live but at least
they're able to get by and when you see
folks who are without their legs or are
without and you see a lot of this stuff
is preventable even the stuff with the
eyes where folks have like cataracts of
sorts and if they just get them removed
for like a grand they can see again but
it's just not funded by anybody um you
see all the things that are stopping
people from living full lives and
they're so easy to fix with so minimal
amount of money but it just goes
unchecked I know seeing somebody who's a
Creator here in the west doing so much
good for people in different parts of
the world is really heartwarming so uh
you know I commend Mr Beast every time I
see this kind of stuff I think it's
amazing and uh yeah yeah I think that's
my thoughts on that anything you want to
say um I wish I I was able to do what he
does you know what I mean give back to
people it's one of the best way to feel
like you're doing something and you make
a difference you know what I mean it's
just to see people happy and just do
good you know you're doing so much
you're getting so much just helping out
others and stuff like that I'm doing my
part I'm doing my things here and there
but at this level I really like what he
does
and I think I would do this same thing
if I had a possibility just doing my
thing on my size as I can but that's
besides the point so I really I really
like his videos and what he does really
like the way he does that [__] I love it
but people are not going to like it and
going to find controversy while not
doing anything at the same time I think
it's a bit weird but it is what it is
you know it's human nature I guess I'll
say it I think Mr be is probably the
best role model on this entire platform
I don't think he's a perfect person I
don't think he's the squeaky CLE person
that some time he has to portray himself
for PRP reasons but uh it doesn't really
matter CU I think the overwhelming good
that he does in the world and the fact
that he broadcasts it and he sets that
example for other people is amazing and
folks you may not be able to do
everything he does but even you can do
it on a smaller scale it's still an
amazing thing to do and I'm pretty
confident he would be saying the same
thing to you guys if you're watching
right now so um yeah if you want to get
involved he's got his Charities that
he's set up and it seems to be all very
legitimate from all the research I've
done do your own um but yeah I um yeah I
guess you just got to grateful that we
have somebody like this as the head of
the platform cuz it could be some
[__] self-absorbed lunatic who just
wants to buy you Bugattis and do other
goofy ass [__] inste we have somebody
like this who's doing this kind of stuff
so I think it's beautiful anything else
no all right let us know what you guys
think in the comments below we want to
hear from
you